[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
welcome to the lords minute our quick
hit video series where we talk about all
the biggest happenings in gaming and
beyond i'm your host ty swenson writer
for lords of gaming and with me today is
lord king
finally the mcu has graced us with our
first look at she-hulk attorney at law
your next big look at a green superhero
near you on disney plus we get a look of
jennifer walters mastering her newfound
superhero abilities alongside her cousin
bruce banner and we also got some sneak
peeks at some possible allies and
villains in this trailer
so king what were you thinking of
she-hulk i was going absolutely nuts
i love all the tropes that they were
doing and all the callbacks um
first shout out to them doing the
commercial for bill bixby
uh you know and
it it feels like a 70s 80s sitcom
which is so built for me
because um of the simple fact that
i grew up on uh lou ferrigno bill bixby
hall
so
at all these people that's out here oh
the cgi
they're trying to get the feel of the
old show
and it came across in a lot in in a lot
of the ways that um that i did see it uh
she did come across as sexy she came
across uh she-hulk herself came across a
little bit more sexy see john byrne used
to um
write uh he used to draw uh she-hulk
back in the days and he brought her back
as the sensational she-hulk because
before that she was a savage seahawk
that she-hulk really didn't captivate
the crowds because we already had a
savage hulk and and you know and
doc bruce david banner um hulk
so what what we now needed was a sexy
hulk a female
hulk something
um
voluptuous and loving right and that
came across when john byrne did
sensational seahawk number one
beautiful issues that's where the
character really got life
and she was uh able to be articulate and
and she's still a lawyer you understand
she had no aspirations of being a
superhero she was just put in superhero
situations
and
i like what they're doing with um
the intelligent hulk well what he's
supposed to be doc green
uh from the comic books he didn't stay
that he he wasn't that green for long
all right so the the extended use of
this character is really uh wearing on
me but they needed to have him
stay dark green
so he can teach her
to be she-hulk so the series he's gonna
be there for a little bit and then more
than likely leave yeah i saw a titania
[Music]
so that means that we should get the
absorbing man
at some point in time and he could have
been in the show uh trailer i don't know
watch it again shout out to frogman all
two seconds yes yes i mean see i'm glad
you saw that so it's it's like so many
different things that were being shown
and you know her dating uh powers
uh her appetite uh
so to say when she started doing the
dating apps and stuff like that
um
this this this series i just can't wait
for it you know and this was the one of
the ones that i was really most excited
for is along with moon knight
this one is what i really want to see
and they got a couple more that's coming
like kamala khan and stuff like that but
this stuff right here is it's you know
what we made our bones
yeah yeah she growing up she hulk has
always been one of those superheroes
that i really admired and enjoyed
basically the different take of
um her persona and power set compared to
bruce banner um and i'm hoping that with
this show of her coming to herself
it doesn't take too long for her for
jennifer walters to open up her shell
into the sensational she-hulk uh
and charismatic version that um
is popular because
the difference with jennifer walter
she-hulk is that she embraces that side
of her
um almost all the time right now of
course we got bruce banner
green but that's only temporary usually
we know bruce banner is often fighting
with his inner demons with the other guy
but she hulk embraces that when she uses
her power she's charismatic she's
cracking jokes
she feels sexy and powerful and that's
something that uh right now
isn't really filled in the mcu and i'm
really excited to see her step into that
plate the trailer shows snips and bits
off her
um doing that like when she's coming out
in that killer dress and then was like
oh yo girl like
that booty though yeah
i i i hope they uh explore the savage
seahawk very uh very quickly at least
for two episodes until she can learn to
get the get it under control
so that's why you know bruce comes in
and starts to explain stuff to her in
the comic books um
she got shot because she was trying a
mob case it was a high profile case and
she got shot needed a blood transfusion
alone behold her blood relative her
cousin the
david david robert david bruce banner
was there
and gave her you know the blood
transfusion and boom she turns into the
she-hulk later on and she's a savage
seahawk for a little bit uh i think
they're going to go along the same lines
as i seen like the car going off the
cliff uh so she might instead of getting
shot she might have to you know be
rushed to the hospital and he comes in
and gives us a transfusion now i don't
know how the hell they're going to give
her a transfusion if he's still
in hulk form so does he turn back and i
didn't get a chance to look at his arm
to see if his arm was still burnt up
from
that period of time so
if it's on if his arm isn't burnt up so
that means that is before the snap
and i mean that's after the snap when
nobody is there before they came back
and um
he's uh learning to come to grips with
doc green is it in between that period
of time i want to know the period of
time that it is and so i got to go back
and watch the trailer
both his arms to see if one of those
arms is still burnt up from
the the
infinity gauntlet so yeah that's my
biggest concern right there for now and
and i see a lot of backlash for the
trailer of um some people taking us time
to bring up old stuff that we still have
doc green blue spanner they're wanting
savage hulk back in which we have
addressed surely we're going to get to
that point um
it's just necessary for now for the
progression of jennifer walter she-hulk
and lastly of course people love to bash
cgi and
count pixels like like they are extreme
experts at home armchair
movie producers um in which
again
it looks fine to me i know we're gonna
get a better product when the show is
actually dropped
that part right there that part exactly
what you what you just said
thank you you know that we're going to
get a better product because
people with any common sense understands
and knows that they cut trail as months
in advance before the final uh um cgi is
uh rendered and sometimes cgi is
rendered up to the final weeks in um
doing production so
i wouldn't be
afraid of anything that i've seen even
if there was a little bit because what i
did see was a little bit of uh timing
issues as far as frame stutter
and that's due to the fact that maybe
they were rendering at uh 22 frames a
second instead of the cinematic 24
frames per second and that's where you
got the little frame stutter but then
they're going to speed all of that stuff
up so a lot of times when we saw with
the mandalorian and all that other stuff
in earlier trailers the earlier trailers
didn't look super polished as much as
the show did so
i i like you said i have no fears in
them rectifying the cgi at all yep yep
when the show does drop though i i'm not
going to complain if if she hook has
a couple extra muscles or some more beef
you know like i got got a love for some
big strong powerful women and so if you
want to just
just
just
a little more on there just a little bit
just a little spring a little bit more
put a little bit show the meat on her
yo when she told that dude let's get
those to go
i said oh yeah
and she was carrying it i was like man
was eating good oh yeah yeah he's going
to the hospital at the end of that but
he definitely had a good time
well
we are very excited for she-hulk to drop
in i think it's uh august right mm-hmm
right right right so we're about to stop
that's starting next week this week and
then we got what kamala khan right after
that and then she hulk should be
somewhere after that i guess right yep
because thor eleven thunder is taking
the july uh slot there we go yeah there
we go so it's about to be a slam pack
summer we are very excited to get the
party started and uh
we're gonna see are we gonna like
jennifer walters when she's angry
but this has been the lord's minute
thank you so much for joining us we're
here every monday wednesday and friday
at lords of gaming.net
i'm ty swenson here with lord king and
this has been
the lord's minute peace
[Music]
you